baywatch was one of the most successful
and long-running tv shows in history
and it became a franchise with multiple
spin-offs made for tv movies and even a
semi-tongue-in-cheek feature film
starring dwayne the rock johnson
here's the inside story of one of the
biggest and most universal phenomena in
pop culture
one of the creators of baywatch greg
bonin worked as a lifeguard himself
patrolling the beaches of los angeles
county throughout the 70s and 80s
one day he mentioned to fellow lifeguard
michael newman that their job might make
for good tv
newman recalled on e true hollywood
story greg goals
if that show chips could make it we
could make a show about lifeguarding
bonan unsuccessfully pitched a show for
10 years then in the late
80s while still working the beaches
bonin rescued the children of stu irwin
an executive at tv production company
mtm enterprises
bonin pitched irwin his series and while
erwin passed
he helped the lifeguard refine his story
looks like we've got a few
stubborn die hards out there a few lucky
connections later
the idea was developed into a show
called baywatch by co-writers michael
burke and douglas schwartz
it was then pitched to cbs that network
said no
but nbc approved a two-hour tv movie
which would also serve as a pilot
called baywatch panic at malibu pier
airing in 1989 panic at malibu pier
ranked among the top 10 most popular
shows of the week
leading nbc to order a baywatch series
set to debut that fall
but early baywatch was less a breezy
swimsuit spectacle and more of an
80s action drama it also wasn't that
popular
finishing at number 60 in the nielsen
ratings edged out by
my two dads and father dowling mysteries
nbc's baywatch run ended after a single
season
cast member billy warlock told esquire
we didn't get cancelled on nbc because
of performance
we just didn't have the money let us
know if you start to lose it mitch
watch and learn grasshopper watch
around that time european baywatch
distributor fremantle asked for another
season of episodes claiming that
overseas demand for the show was strong
co-creator douglas schwartz consulted
his uncle brady bunching gilligan's
island creator sherwood schwartz
having had major success syndicating
reruns of those shows
sherwin suggested the baywatch team buy
back the rights to their show
get a new production company and enter
into the lucrative syndicated tv market
check the schedule by late 1991 baywatch
was ready to go
all over again as an unproven startup
the first few seasons of baywatch had to
do things a lot cheaper than they had
with nbc
fremantle offered 300 000 an episode
banking in particular on the show's
advertising revenue potential in germany
where david hasselhoff was a huge star
for both tv and music uk-based tv
network
itv threw in some money too provided
that baywatch featured no gun use and
never depict violent acts against women
or children
still producers had to cut costs
including star david hasselhoff's salary
don't put me in the middle of this hoff
agreed to a 50
reduction in his acting fee in exchange
for an executive producer credit which
made him eligible for a chunk of the
profits
should the show find lasting success
according to fox business hasselhoff
wound up earning about 100 million
dollars for his involvement in baywatch
other lesser-known stars of the show
didn't make much however taking home per
episode paychecks in the 2500 to 5 000
range obviously baywatch was popular
otherwise it wouldn't have run for more
than 200 episodes over more than a
decade
launched the careers of multiple people
and inspired a movie of the same name
but what is a little surprising is how
staggeringly popular the show was at the
peak of its run
by the mid 90s each episode was viewed
by 1.1 billion people on average
across more than 142 countries and
translated into 15 languages
with the world population just under 6
billion at the time
that means roughly 1 in 5 people
worldwide
tuned into baywatch broken down into
male and female viewers
one might assume that the swimsuit
clad's audience was overwhelmingly male
but according to the la times
about two-thirds of baywatch viewers
were women the reason
according to co-creator greg bonan is
that its female characters were
positive role models who were athletic
professional intelligent and able to
make any
rescue a man can make hey you okay
something wrong
nothing at vacation wouldn't fix
baywatch was never a critically
acclaimed show but it was fine with its
place in the tv landscape
as a source of eye candy a near-constant
stream of pretty people and skimpy
outfits running on the beach
made baywatch memorable as a show slight
in content
but heavy on the visuals yeah it's a
tough job
douglas schwartz helped shape the
aesthetic both as a co-creator of the
series and a director of 43 episodes
and three made for tv baywatch movies
all while qualifying as
legally blind diagnosed with extreme
tunnel vision
schwartz told the new york times my
vision is 10 degrees
most people see 180 degrees but
everything i could see was in camera
according to schwartz he's the only
legally blind person to ever be admitted
into the director's guild of america
baywatch made stars out of many
up-and-coming performers
notably pamela anderson as lifeguard cj
parker and a pre-beard pre-aquaman jason
momoa
but only a handful of actors could be a
part of the show at any given time
leaving plenty of famous and talented
people
off the beach oh my god it's hulk hogan
as the story goes scream star nev
campbell auditioned but didn't fit in
while future a-list star sandra bullock
canceled a scheduled audition
desperate housewives star terry hatcher
was almost cast
according to co-creator michael burke
while 90's pop singer and dancer paula
abdul
nearly replaced original cast member
erika olynyk
ultimately losing the role of cj parker
to pamela anderson
david hasselhoff secured the lead role
of lifeguard chief mitch buchanan
but he almost passed the former knight
rider leading man read the pilot script
and initially rejected the role
recalling in his memoir
don't hassle the hoth that he told his
agent it was quote
basically knight rider in a bathing suit
it's basically
michael knight running down the beach in
a bathing suit with beautiful women
saving lives in the ocean he obviously
changed his mind and got the gig
after producers rejected other 80s tv
star wars like tom wolpat
lorenzo llamas and william cat
jeremy jackson portrayed hobie buchanan
for nine baywatch seasons
but he wasn't the producer's first
choice he began his stretch at just nine
years old
winding up with the role after another
slightly older actor had almost landed
the part
15 year old leonardo dicaprio michael
burke told the hollywood reporter
we actually had dicaprio ready to be
cast so what happened
hasselhoff happened hobie is the son of
his baywatch character mitch
and hasselhoff thought that if a teen
was portraying his son
it would make him seem substantially
older than if a child were to take the
part
douglas schwartz added he had a lot of
concerns of that type
but producers ignored hasselhoff's
concerns when in season two they brought
on pamela anderson
best known for her work on home
improvement and in playboy
oh my god i'm sorry i'm just so
surprised to see you standing there
not as surprised as i was hasselhoff
objected to anderson's casting
claiming that baywatch was a family show
and no place for a playboy bunny
he also thought anderson could be well
distracting
schwartz said she had these enormous
breasts and david thought he would be
upstaged by
everyone looking at her breasts which is
what happened
apart from hot lifeguards and red
swimsuits the most memorable
images from baywatch are its countless
slow motion shots of heroic lifeguards
and women in bikinis running across the
sand to a soft rock soundtrack
by the time that show went into
production in the late 80s the slo-mo
influence of chariots of fire was still
being felt
and apparently it influenced greg bonan
too
michael burke told esquire greg had just
gotten back from shooting the olympics
namely sprinters in the 100 yard dash in
slow motion
come on guys let's go all right the
show's over go back and do what you were
doing
it was a stylistic choice for sure but
it was also a practical measure and a
cost-saving technique for producers
hasselhoff wrote in his book they'd say
to the second unit crew
we're five minutes short go shoot
another montage
grab the most beautiful extra and shoot
her running down the beach in slow
motion
it looks good though don't you think
lost isn't the only primary beach set
show with a huge cast
over its 11 seasons and more than 240
episodes
more than 50 actors were a part of the
main cast of baywatch
they made for one of the biggest casts
in tv history
partially because the show was in
production for so long
but there were plenty of other reasons
for the show's revolving door-like
personnel changes
douglas schwartz claimed that sometimes
people were cast simply because of their
agreeable appearance
telling esquire carmen elektra tracy
bingham and michael bergen
were all examples of that they would
look good in a swimsuit they can do the
action they could swim
they just as actors were not strong
enough so we wouldn't give them big
story lines
hi i'm kelly garrett the producer
claimed yasmine bleath was
quote doing drugs at the time and when
it started influencing her work
baywatch parted ways with her electra
quit because she said the show wasn't a
good fit for her
and pam anderson eventually walked away
too in order to focus on raising her two
sons
baywatch shot primarily on location on
real california beaches with
all of their benefits and risk the pilot
movie baywatch panic at malibu pier
filmed in january 1989 when the water
off the coast of southern california was
a chilly if not dangerous 49 degrees
even worse according to hasselhoff the
water was loaded with garbage
feces and hypodermic needles production
was halted and moved to hawaii when cast
members contracted a stomach virus
still for the first episode the ocean
wasn't as clear and refreshing as it
looked on tv
according to the hoff in order to
prevent cast members from getting
extremely sick from various toxic
elements
he wrote we were doused and disinfectant
by medics every time we came out of the
water
according to hasselhoff's autobiography
baywatch producers saw about 40 hopefuls
for the role of cj parker before
eventually hiring pamela anderson
and unbeknownst to producers she
happened to be dating cast member david
charvet at the time
maybe i should have run into his arms
like a romance novel and
kissed him in the sand with the waves
crashing over us pam and david
eventually split
and anderson eloped with motley crue
drummer tommy lee in 95
charvet meanwhile left the show in 96
but not before a romantic
on-screen kiss-filled goodbye between
his character and hers
that scene filmed on a day when lee just
so happened to be visiting the set
and he didn't handle it very well
douglas schwartz told esquire
tommy lee was so upset that pamela was
kissing david charvet
that he destroyed pamela's dressing room
kicked in the door smashed her mirrors
and her windows and things like that
we had to have security escort him off
the set and then he was barred from ever
coming on the set again
in 96 lee and anderson explicit homemade
video leaked to the public
according to the new york times reps for
many outlets that aired baywatch
called for anderson's removal from the
series and producers worried about
losing ad revenue
and of potential cancellation but the
opposite happened
in the aftermath of the tape baywatch
scored its highest ratings
ever after nine seasons baywatch started
getting stale
so in 1999 it rebooted itself as
baywatch hawaii
moving both the setting and filming to
the beautiful island state
the move was moderately successful with
producers squeezing two more seasons out
of the aging franchise
if i'm lucky if i'm real lucky
i'll find what i'm looking for i'll find
me who knows if it would have lasted
even longer had the original plan to
make baywatch down under not falling
apart
at the time it was cheaper to film in
australia than california
and production took advantage of the
lower cost filming a two-part episode in
sydney as a tryout before making a
permanent move
local residents strongly objected after
members of the production overstepped
their bounds
allegedly escorting a surfer off the
beach and forcing out noisy
skateboarding teams
area citizens also feared that in the
future they'd have diminished access to
the beach
and they didn't want to deal with the
possibility of lookie lou taurus
baywatch producers also demanded 200 000
from the australian government to offset
costs arguing that the show would
ultimately add 18 million annually to
the local economy
if you're going to stay you better try
these
[Music]
very nice after more than 700 residents
showed up for a heated public hearing on
the matter the production backed off on
its long-term plans
but only after a contingent from hawaii
offered a better deal
where did that leave baywatch 11 seasons
245 episodes
and the number one watch show on the
planet
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you